you
we're hoping that it's a real catalyst
for cycling in the area it's been a
fantastic day with many visitors coming
from all over the region and those
people following the torso yeah we're
very excited by having a Pretoria you
know and i think it's the first time
it's been here for a long time it's just
your excitement and see and obviously a
lot of got the cyclists that are quite
well known wonderful outdoor environment
is obviously very tough cycling yes is
anything but flat to the air and
sunshine and there it goes probably
about them this year we've just got so
many people supporting the event it
means that the profile of cycling is
raised enormously not just on Dartmoor
but on South Devon as well in all of
difference and it means that people who
perhaps previously didn't think about
coming to Dartmoor to do cycling or to
get out and don't let's do activities
and now considering it and looking at
the countryside what the defense could
become you've got the scenery but the
hills or the downhills fairly empty most
it's great kind of seeing how beautiful
is it might attract people into the
areas kind of holiday as well SAT me and
bring their bikes around it enjoy what
we could take granted possibly
dartmoor offers a wide range of
opportunities for cyclists within the
National Park and from anything from a
quiet family cycle ride through through
forests or quiet quiet lanes to more
challenging off-road cycling routes same
across the open more cyclists have been
visiting the area in greater numbers for
the last few years and it's something we
definitely want to support continuously
council with Devon County Council and
the district councils in our area we're
making a big effort to increase the
cycling opportunities we're dedicated
cycleways what we're trying to do is
introduce trails for pedestrian as well
as a cyclist to take let's say families
together introduce riding in the
children teaching their children to ride
and the camera thing to take them off
road
specially in track it's events like
these and having big names like Mark
Cavendish who has 120 station before
threads coming through here that brings
bring the toys and anything to help us
portal to get I think you should have
healthy life having all these people
you'd be surprised where a lot of them
come from
the tour of britain announces said that
hey torrid it got the records their
number of people for any part of the
tour so far so that's that's really
fantastic you know it's been brilliant a
thing to have this backdrop of the
Dartmoor for the cycle to go through so
hopefully it will help to promote
Dartmoor and boost tourism I think it
would be very difficult in ladera to
have big races like their top siblings
the profile of Cambridge way up having a
big big corporate and races up around
the team which is very good for the
county this cycling forest is something
that you see a lot of activity endeavor
and the things that you will find from a
holiday in this area in South Devon is
that more to short feel really so we're
looking at developing the link-up
between the Moors and everything that
offers down to places such as timnath
with the temper way it's a real
possibility and that's an area that
we're looking to promote over the coming
months and hopefully families will get
together and go and visit the rule terms
which will be joined by a cycle track
this leg has been the most challenging
for the experience cyprus but everybody
can go at their own pace we've got
neither the winding lanes on the level
thus luleå coastal resorts are on the
level we've got lovely from an ardent
images and everything or something for
everybody we're a microcosm of of
interest in this area it's just a super
place to be we'd like to see more
cyclists here on more production more
operative ism and more safer cycling
group
so it's an area that we're prepared put
a lot of time and effort in and we will
work slavish Lee over the next three or
four years to promote that and this has
been a catalyst today where we will then
move forward with the energy we felt
from the tour of britain coming to hate
or to a better future for cycling